you know out here in Los Angeles in in
some of this industry and stuff that I'm
in there's it's not a rejection against
Christ but there's definitely you know
religion isn't super welcomed people
want to be offended or people want you
know a lot of this is vibe out here
sometimes I feel like the oh you're
gonna offend oh you can't have you know
there's something weird about faith you
know or in some areas people are like
thoughts and prayers that kind of you
don't like that but man I feel like
faith is just such a healing thing for
people yeah I feel alone I feel
hitchhiking when I you know if I don't
have some kind of a faith and I say not
you know as I even talked about this I
realized that my faith isn't very strong
right now and that it can really be
tightened up and um but yeah to feel I
mean the you know having faith that's a
free parent you get a free parent I
meant I'm not thinking I'm out here in
this world that's all for me this is all
on my back that I have no point that I'm
that I don't have an umbilical cord to
some sort of being now Jesus Christ man
that was the most popular guy in my area
growing up you know I think you do too
zoo is a great role model he I think he
could be the Son of God I think a lot I
think you know his brother could be
who's a little chubby guy that positive
baby that little fruit that bad boy
eating fruits in the diaper Buddha maybe
Buddha's his brother and mother nature
is their sister and yin and yang are
their Asian cousins and you got this one
big beautiful family of people that when
we feel alone we don't have to are when
we
then we don't have to I can't and look I
know some people out there atheists and
stuff and they don't want to believe in
anything and that's you know and I just
I can't understand understand it but I
also come from a place where I think
I've felt alone a lot and so if you're
telling me that there is a free /
there's a free being a free body a free
parent a free love a free heart out
there in the universe
that will help me not feel alone man
came and that's a lottery ticket that I
don't have to scratch man I'll take that
all day I'll take that all day cuz I
want to be a part of something bigger I
don't want to be a part of just myself
you know and I want to leave here and I
want to see I want to feel something
again I want to feel something again
even if it's just the feeling of if your
spirit touching the spirit of your
parents or your grandparents or of your
sister or if one of your ancestors or
somebody else is saying just a feeling
of your spirit bumping into somebody
else's in another world that's safe and
normal they're comfortable maybe not
even normal some some new normal I don't
know I'll take that chance man [ __ ] I'd
love to be a ghost bro do can you
imagine if we get to be ghosts imagine
being ghosts you eat everything you eat
just falls right on the floor
I would love that I think Jesus Christ
would be a great guest I think he'd be
great to talk to I think that'd be a
nice person to sit down and have lunch
with you know I think it's a great role
model you know I uh I don't want to not
have any faith man I feel like it's it's
odd I don't want to not have any and now
I'm iope I'm open to figuring out where
that faith lies you know one thing I was
interesting for me was when I started to
travel and go to other countries and see
that other people believed in different
in different gods oh it was not fair to
me to then think oh well none of these
people go to heaven or none of these
people go to an afterlife are only my
God is the only one but you got to
believe in something good I mean I ain't
accepting any of these cats believing in
the dark arts you know that thinking all
the treasures right here on earth that's
tricky man that's it just seems cold I
just see man and look I'm opening a bit
to learn and uh but for me the way the
religion has always been most
comfortable in my life in my environment
when I grew up was Catholicism or
Baptists you know Presbyterians did I
thought Presbyterians were honestly
lesbians I didn't know I thought I
didn't know I mixed it up when I was
young dude now I'd hear those bells ring
and I would you know I'd be like dang
they got a lot of ladies heading over
there a lot of ladies boy gonna be
packing into that building because I
thought Presbyterians were you know
straight-up lesbians but but that's
different
Wow you know it's crazy as my sister
can't even read but what does it have to
do with us right now hope you enjoyed
that video and you can watch another and
you can watch this one you can watch
this one different options different
choices some guy just brings you one
option not this guy two options watch
one this one